muito obrigado pela vossa presença dizer
que é sempre uma honra estar diante de
uma atividade tão importante cima e nós
vamos começar por este primeiro o que eu
tenho aqui é o que estava com saudades
nos nossos ancestrais com trecho palmas
é muito simples
alongue coco a long long long
olá
o lucro andou akuku olho em bonn akuku
rolo cohen boa akuku olho com emboa cuco
olho com o emo
o loco é mou akuku olho quando o lucro é
boa a kuo 1 e pode levar o e siriri lá
ea total e na namíbia irão bt ea carga
horária total e cair e live aid
eu tinha um grande vilão da noite bom no
ângulo e atitude am
a aae kandir e lá e acordo com a lei
kandir zelândia e na net ganhava a
dagong bola ganhar vaga do volante com a
ganhar a dagong ganhar a vaga olímpica
ganhar vai dar volume kuhna ganhar a
vaga do volante foi a campeã na vaga o
nome silva ganhava vai dar volume ficou
a ganhar vaga o nome
o lula tá rolando o lateral rodrigo vai
rolando cola ganhar a vaga o nome
popular ganhará vaga golos foram ganhar
a wii u to a wii wii
sejam bem vindos
é tão lento
o nó
um bom lugar
andou rotina oca e sinhá
loooool dólar
o dono tinta voto e sinhá erwin são da
furg nenê que o catar também avisou que
haverá pô
roni tang o tio louca porque pan
ah
ia ser levado a haia e foram muito bem
o levantou o roma lua do mix a bom
evitar que o vê e não admite correr por
mo mixa ganhou nó um gol lá é longo
vamos lá
o campo em que o time engrene lombo lá
rolar outra 1 em 1991
to go to kill a calar e com um sonho e
um anito apague hua camarim muito 8 num
dólar
a bomba no vôo o lombo lombo rolar não
motiva
loooool lá longe eu morri na vida não
vou não to borrow ouvi na vida mudou
tanto
ae
don balón lobón baiano não boró do
morumbi na verdade nunca se fosse na li
não canse tatu namorada não move na
renda que não mobiliza ainda ham não
e uma mão do dono e não irão não pode
até estudar a atingir tão filão do
mundial
o filme tal de dirley retirar me da lei
é um filme tão vil e não viu então
dirley estudo do the earth a onu é um é
um
eu gostava patatá
na pec
a galera
i
o gol foi um muito obrigado a embarcar o
ine é filho de camponeses com munição
também aqui no entanto eu sou neto de
caçadores
filho de camponeses mesmo também
e trago comigo uma bagagem histórica que
provavelmente dará um livro
sou filho de guerra tinha sido raptado
de quatro anos nas matas
mas antes disso a minha vida estava
entre o mato ea cidade
portanto eu vivia no mato com as mães
avós mas também frequentava cidade
porque pode ter pouco freqüentar a
igreja o seminário bem dizer era
praticamente uma região próxima da
cidade
mas a minha vida toda tudo que eu puder
absorver é sobre a tradição oral é hoje
trago entanto uma bagagem que envolve um
pacote musical que envolve um conjunto
de conhecimento que está ligado à música
ou a tradição através dos valores que eu
busco ou seja eu vivo na cidade ou lido
com asfalto lido com os prédios mas eu
procuro e no interior para poder buscar
valores da maneira que eu não possa
perder esta minha identidade é o meu
foco é a minha missão e da maneira que
eu possa também alguma forma transmitido
com segurança
a música que eu faço
as duas músicas que eu acabei de compor
a primeira faz parte do pacote pesquisa
como pesquisador cultural é uma música
que foi composta pela minha avó ea mãe
em 1954
exato a música retrata momentos de
incentivo na fase de coleta e esta
música também se havia da canção de roda
no final do do período laboral
portanto a as mães avós folião se a
minha mãe tanto reunião se e ficavam ia
cantar não é a volta de uma fogueira e
eu absorvi aquele conhecimento todo
então estamos que acabou por ser uma
música do coletivo ou seja um patrimônio
coletivo familiar e hoje eu tenho da
música como título do álbum do álbum
porque o que o álbum com o título de um
álbum bem
resumidamente toca é pesquisador
cultural
mas antes disso fazia exercia outras
funções que estão ligados à engenharia
como muitos falaram aqui engenharia
enfim outras coisas professorado
mas desde pequeno eu cresci com uma
pressão por parte dos pais camponeses
que são tiver um sonho de ver um filho
engenheiro
então eu presenciava uma jogada
diferente eles queriam de mim que fosse
diferente também
ou seja é absorvido a tradição oral é
absorver o conhecimento sobre os hábitos
e costumes absorver valores de um povo
culturalmente falando que eles queriam
que eu fosse um dia de petróleo
não queria que eu seguisse o sonho eu
via a minha meu avô a caçar tanto a
dançar tudo aquilo e eu 35 o quilo é
isto que fique aqui a propagação dos
sons
enquanto a minha volta vavá pelas costas
ea lavrando e aquela posição dos sons
ainda vivia ou seja aquilo que ficava
comigo então eu dizia à minha mãe que eu
queria ser músico e ela dizia não do
texto que sem dinheiro para salvar a
família
onde será que a única forma de salvar a
não existe um outro
tudo foi acontecendo enquanto criança
zero na escola no seminário e depois de
um álbum foi raptado por que eu fazia
essa trajetória do mato para a cidade
foi ali onde fui raptado fiz quatro anos
tem uma história muito muito muito
triste porque o meu amigo pessoal
um amigo de confiança o seminário serviu
de escudo não é emprego em pleno
confronto confronto tanto foi retirado
estava pelas minhas costas significa
dizer que se eu não tivesse morreu então
um monte de coisas que eu pude ver mas
mesmo assim quando saí das matas
eu não me deixei levar pela frustração
eu acreditei eu acreditei e graças a
este percurso que consegui me soltar dos
países e comecei a a lutar pela vida uma
vida que muitos de vocês já tiveram uma
coisa triste pior mas pronto é a própria
vida
e daí que eu comecei a a procurar
correndo atrás dos meus sonhos vive
entre o desejo que gere a preferência
e já que eu tenha maturidade suficiente
para decidir entregar os diplomas
diplomas não nos pais elas receberam
diplomas e disse olha vou seguir meu
caminho eu vou ter câncer aquilo que
sempre preferi ser que é ser homem de
cultura
o músico eles eram pai não faça isso
filho vai degradar a família por causa
do filho que a gente confia o filho que
está para salvar a família disse não mas
eu vou salvar a família dele na mente de
uma forma diferente
eu vou levar o teu nome além fronteira
só da família dá cá estou aqui para
poder recuperar o que se perdeu no
passado
obrigado
muito obrigado frontera
mais do que isso vou cantar é novo noé e
goiânia e carlão bem como a mandioca o
chapão e eu ele é e o futebol que bito
capinan lomba onde ia
a sucuri ninguém me o tiny toons do
louco tá ralinho substitui um gol para o
b boy é suco abobrinha tiozinho ódio
total atingiu a é e wap um bebê com a
gente
run to go havia chance hoje é totalmente
o aluno ao erro o atrium beba sucos
quadrilha tinha chance outro garantiu
assumam a 681 beba
o tite a menina pouco e disso a bituca e
mulher eu a criancinha ao mar 11 na
calcinha
mallon vozinha e e acolher a economia o
galati huaihai se quadrilha chance to
coletivo até 41 baby kids ro julgou a
madrinha to see how to uma baleia com a
bíblia em luanda e atingiu se o outro
coletivo atuando aguentei até ontem um
bem guardado
eis o atleta tinham seguinte o objetibvo
só tem a romã é um bom ficar ouvidoria
do túnel e cavou então eu acho que é um
bandido técnica ele pegou a moto em
antioch hall onde o total de barra do
imbuí e assim subir a trilha to assim
sua linha de 11
subo a vinha de 11
assim google não vai de novo perdão o
edil a domingo em single don't want to
contigo não foi de bom nível
joga tão bem ganha a vaga no vôo
governar eu tô sozinha quando apaga tudo
balela bom ali ele disse que ia cair
privalia no futuro em campo não bate a
técnica e ganhou a marca o gol de mão ea
mãe tava aí né não
estou apagando amanhã
meu deus meu deus
ah ah ah minha mãe tentou apagar a apple
entrou a ganhar a honra ea imagem do
apagão e põe tudo bancar
vamos cantar um caminho que vai entoar
placar
há algo que é pai e tua pagar hora
agora é quarto apanhar agora está
fraquinho
a all ea enquanto a bancar basta-me área
há algo a alguém
e quanto a pagar um bom time e vamos ali
bom obrigado para vocês é senhora muito
obrigado a acompanhar o pai de roupa
enquanto apanhar
há também boas e más